welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i am the
special temporary primary host of the
show today i am joined by greg knuckles
he is currently the permanent
guest co-host for now um on an ongoing
basis
um we've got a lot to cover in today's
episode a lot of great content but
before we get to that uh you might be
one of the many people who feels like
you enjoy the podcast and also feel like
you want to support the podcast and of
course that would be greatly appreciated
and there are many ways to do that you
could
like rate or subscribe wherever you
happen to access this show you could
join our email newsletter at
strongerbyscience.com newsletter you can
check out our coaching program we have a
lot of very talented coaches over at
strongerbyscience.com
coaching they offer one-on-one coaching
for training and sports nutrition you
could use our discount code at
bulksupplements.com
the code is sbs pod that gets you a five
percent discount off of your entire
order you could subscribe to the mass
research review a monthly research
review covering all the most important
studies in exercise and nutrition and
finally you could subscribe to macro
factor that is the diet app that we
created and it's got a free trial which
is great because you can take it for a
spin see if you like it and we think you
will uh greg road to the stage how's it
going you know what actually let me say
one thing about uh bulk supplements real
quick okay so uh i just learned this
recently
i i feel like i shouldn't admit this
publicly but here i go i personally
don't take creatine i think it's great i
just forget to take supplements and so i
don't take supplements uh but
apparently there's a creatine shortage
uh a journalist reached out to me uh
maybe like a month ago asking like hey
what do you know about the creatine
shortage and i said
nothing but here are some people who
might uh and apparently it's reached the
point that there were some posts in the
stronger by science facebook group uh
within the last week or two like
hey the place i typically get creatine
is either out or their prices are up
like 400 percent like
where do where can i go to get creatine
i just checked and at least as of the
time of recording uh creatine
monohydrate is in stock in bulk
supplements uh and you know since it is
a
like a wholesale provider uh i think
their prices are up relative to where
they used to be
um but you can still get like a kilogram
for
56 bucks and i haven't done this math
but i feel like a kilo of creatine is
gonna last you for like three years uh
so
yep if uh if the creatine shortage is
biting you right now uh you can still
get it for a good price at
bulksupplements.com
yeah these are strange times i i've seen
threads about people trying to figure
out where to get creatine and even just
where to get meat like some people have
been struggling to get their hands on
chicken breast or they're finding it at
you know really really inflated prices
so uh that's definitely some important
news to share all right so now actual
road to the stage uh don't have too much
to say uh i did hit a new low this past
week but haven't broken into the 225s
yet which will be
the next uh the next milestone of sorts
um but yeah uh overall things are going
good but no nothing nothing really
warranting uh going in depth about
good stuff um i have
virtually nothing to share about the
road to athens
smooth sailing things are going
relatively well
i've been super busy the last couple
weeks doing a whole bunch of writing so
i haven't had a lot of time to
tackle a lot of my training and rehab
head on it's basically just been getting
in and moving around enough to maintain
what i've got
uh and you know basically just
exercising to maintain health and
happiness like
if i truly skip all exercise for a
couple weeks
i just don't seem to be as happy a
person um so yeah i've just been getting
in there having fun moving around trying
to use some muscles so that they don't
fully atrophy uh so yeah nothing really
to share there
what about feats of strength yeah so
this is uh this is one of the rare feats
of strength that i have to put
a a spoiler alert disclaimer on so uh
this is about the person who recently
won the world's strongest man
competition
and the reason i say spoiler alert is
world strongest man is also televised
but it's televised like several months
after the fact
so
the competition just took place and if
you want to wait to find out who wins
until you can actually watch the
competition on tv uh
you know skip the rest of this segment
but if that doesn't bother you uh
i'm about to give the name so three two
one uh tom stoltman won again back to
back
and
this was uh
i would say a pretty a pretty dominating
performance uh he
i think beat second place by like 11
points which is a pretty comfortable
victory uh in world's strongest man
and uh
he he had to feel really good going into
the last event so tom tom stoltman is a
very good all-around strong man but he
if he's known for one event it's atlas
stones like he's
uh he's the current god of atlas stones
and and maybe
this is this is more debatable but you
could make a strong case
that he is the best at atlas stones of
all time like you you might put
like peak thor in that conversation you
might put pound stone in that
conversation you might put peak brian
shaw in that conversation but
tom stoltman is definitely on the mount
rushmore of uh of atlas stone uh loaders
and so he was he was up going into atlas
stone so he he had to know that the
competition was in the bag
and he went ahead and took first on that
event to uh to seal a pretty comfortable
victory uh so congrats to him tom
stoltman back to back world's strongest
man champion
all right good stuff
um so for the content in today's episode
uh i've got a little research roundup
just a little bit of a brief update on
buffering supplements um because there's
been a couple papers that both hit the
press this past month uh that are worth
diving into so i think we'll start there
um you know this past month uh if you're
a math subscriber you're actually going
to get some more
in-depth updates about these studies on
june 1st
the june 1st issue is going to cover
some of this stuff but
uh yeah there are two papers that came
out recently one was on beta alanine and
another one was a study on a combination
of anserine and carnosine and that's a
combination that i've discussed on the
podcast before
as extremely preliminary research and
i'm
moving that up a category to very
preliminary research so it is making its
way toward being a household name and a
supplement staple uh one rung of that
ladder at a time
so starting with uh what might be
considered some of the bad news i think
um
or good news depending on your
perspective i think you know my
interactions with the fitness world
is largely people who do resistance
training uh largely because they're into
powerlifting they're into bodybuilding
whether they compete or not
or they're more of a hobbyist they're
interested in changing their physique
getting stronger
but you know we don't you know we
certainly love to have people in our
audience who are into a variety of
different pursuits crossfit strong man
etc you know but we are not a crossfit
heavy brand explicitly you know so we we
get a lot of people who are into various
pursuits within lifting but a lot of
times the people i see supplementing the
most with beta alanine from my window
into the fitness world
it's people who are largely interested
in hypertrophy outcomes
it's a lot of people who are doing a lot
of their training in that
you know 8 10 12 reps per set maybe they
throw in some sets of 15. they take at
least a minute rest between sets uh
sometimes up to two or three depending
on the exercise and you know for the
heavy compounds even greater or they're
just people who are uh uh general
pre-workout enthusiasts yeah or people
who love pre-workouts and said hey
there's beta-alanine in here that's
terrific yeah i've heard of that and it
seems to work for something you know
which is definitely true but uh what's
really interesting about the
beta-alanine research is that um
you would think for for a supplement
that's so well established
you would assume that there's a lot more
very direct lifting research with beta
alanine
and there's actually a lot of gaps in
that literature there's there's not as
much pure
ecologically valid lifting research with
beta alanine as you would probably think
now there's a lot of research on beta
alanine uh largely focusing on a bunch
of lab-based exercise tests that are
frankly designed to determine if
beta-alanine does what it's supposed to
do right so beta-alanine is supposed to
increase muscle carnosine
carnosine is an intracellular buffer
so when you're doing high intensity
glycolytic exercise very carbohydrate
dependent exercise and you are
generating a bunch of lactate and you're
accumulating a bunch of excess uh
hydrogen ions a bunch of excess protons
kind of floating around in there uh
carnosine comes in handy because it
helps buffer some of those excess
hydrogen ions
and what that does is it delays
some of those drops in localized ph and
as a result
it delays fatigue to some extent so that
is kind of the premise of beta alanine
supplementation is it's helping with
buffering it's uh reducing or delaying
the onset of that localized acidosis and
that seems to be implicated as a fatigue
reducing mechanism
in this type of glycolytic exercise so a
lot of the beta alanine research like i
said they use lab-based exercise tests
that are you know uh sprints that that
last for you know somewhere between 30
seconds and two minutes or or they do
really intensive repeated sprint
exercise bouts and what they're trying
to do is really
hammer that glycolytic uh energy system
you know that anaerobic energy system
that is so carbohydrate dependent and
they're trying to
uh really ramp up the uh the acidosis
induced by exercise so they don't say
hey what's the perfect exercise test for
this give them a set of eight like
that's not how you really uh design an
exercise protocol to make beta alanine
maximally useful yeah but what's
interesting is a lot of people use it in
this uh this context of trying to
promote hypertrophy within a standard
hypertrophy focus training program so
like i said
8 10 12 maybe 15 reps per set you know
plenty of rest between sets um you know
just to make sure that you're able to to
give it your best with the next uh the
next set coming up and there's really
not a ton of research looking at how
beta alanine impacts this specific type
of exercise there are
you know you know some certainly
research papers looking at various
lifting outcomes but when you look at
the results they're not as consistent as
and as conclusive as you'd like to see
you know there's some uh
variability from study to study in terms
of outcomes and there's just generally a
relative lack of research compared to
what you might expect so there is a
recent paper that i am going to link in
the show notes they were looking at beta
alanine supplementation
6.4 grams per day the cumulative dose
should have been adequate to achieve an
ergogenic effect um you know in theory
um
but unfortunately you know within this
program that the participants were doing
about 12 reps per set
three sets per exercise going to you
know concentric failure and resting a
minute between sets resting two minutes
between exercises beta alanine in this
particular study really just didn't do
much at all in terms of facilitating
hypertrophy
or facilitating strength gains i think
it was eight maybe ten weeks or so in
duration uh so the dose per day was high
enough the duration was long enough the
cumulative dose should have been
sufficient for beta alanine to do what
it's supposed to do and in this case uh
you know beta alanine just really didn't
do much for this program now it was an
eight-week study eight-week study yeah
that's what i thought
um so
the uh
the uh takeaway here is based on this
research based on this particular study
not very promising for the people who
like to use beta alanine within the
context of a pretty standard pretty
typical hypertrophy program
now
nine or ten people per group one study
of course we don't want to get too
carried away and kind of put the nail in
the coffin of beta-alanine um but
there's not really a ton of research
suggesting that beta-alanine directly is
efficacious within this type of training
program and here is one piece of
evidence that chips away at some of our
confidence in that conclusion and so for
me going into this study um my suspicion
was that if you were doing sets of 12 go
into failure only one minute of rest
between sets i would have anticipated a
small benefit from beta alanine and when
i say small
when you're talking about standardized
effect size categories what i really
mean is trivial but for a lot of people
trivial matters uh in terms of you know
if it's non-zero reliably we'll take it
in a lot of cases so i was expecting
probably a
trivial effect of beta alanine in this
context uh that's not what was observed
and we're going to need some more
research to really dig into this to
figure out exactly how specialized beta
alanine is for lifters uh you know we
know for certain um well
that's about as as bold as statements
i'd ever make so there is a very large
body of evidence suggesting that beta
alanine is effective when you are doing
you know truly purely anaerobic
glycolytic sprint type exercise when
you're if you're doing exhaustive bouts
of exercise that are two minutes in
duration and you're doing several of
them like beta alanine
ought to help in that scenario there's
plenty of evidence to suggest that but
when it comes to lifting applications
this study uh like i said chips away at
our confidence that it has a lot of
utility in a typical hypertrophy program
with that kind of standard hypertrophy
rep range and the standard one or two
minutes of rest between sets uh i still
believe uh based on
mostly mechanistic uh theory
that beta alanine probably has
applications when it comes to things
like crossfit uh other forms of circuit
type training
strongman medleys possibly uh depending
on exactly how the medley is put
together
so i i'm not ready to say
that beta alanine is useless for
hypertrophy or for the typical
hypertrophy program but um we
we don't yet have a definitive line
where we say
these are the programming uh
characteristics that make use of beta
alanine and these are the programming
characteristics at which it becomes
useless we don't really know where that
line is and we don't know which side of
the line
uh typical hypertrophy programming falls
on so it's an area where we're gonna
need some more research and like i said
if you're into hypertrophy focus
training
and uh you've been using beta alanine
because uh you know you
like me anticipated that it would be at
least somewhat helpful in these
applications uh like i said this could
be good news or bad news uh it could be
good news because you say oh great i
don't have to spend money on it anymore
and i don't have to you know take the
two grams like you know three or four
times throughout the day depending on
how you split it up so you know beta
alanine is kind of a pain to dose
several times throughout the day to
avoid all the tingling um so you might
look at this as a good thing or you
might look at it as a bad thing because
you say hey i
i kind of have that sunk cost where i've
been using beta alanine for so long and
paying for it i was hoping it was doing
something for me maybe it's not um
again i want to reiterate we're talking
about small sample research we're
talking about one finding we shouldn't
get too carried away um but i do think
there's a a perspective
uh that's very common which is that beta
alanine is a slam dunk for hypertrophy
type training and i don't think we're
quite ready to make that type of
conclusion yet yeah so if i could if i
could kind of swing in here with with a
bit of theory and and i'll admit on the
front end uh this was your segment so i
did not uh
you know do a lit search put things in
the outline so the things i'm about to
say
i
know i've seen research supporting it
but it won't be in the show notes so
just take my word for it um
but uh
so one
one interesting thing i think is i i
think
that people
anticipate that for lifting related
outcomes uh that buffering
is going to improve performance more
than it actually will
and i think that's based on
what used to be a very reasonable and
seemingly well supported assumption that
when your ph drops in your muscles that
that
uh just like like mechanistically
interferes with muscle contraction
reduces force output and therefore
reduces performance but there there have
been some mechanistic studies uh within
the last like five years or so
investigating whether or not that's
actually the case
so
essentially there's a difference between
the effect of ph per se
and
the
way you would get to a low muscle ph
just via exercise um and so essentially
you need to be able to separate those
two to investigate how much changes in
ph
actually affect muscle contractile
performance and so there have been some
studies where essentially what they do
is they just isolate muscle fibers and
they like so like bathe them in
solutions with different phs and then
just look to see like hey how acidic of
a solution do muscle fibers have to be
in before
contractile performance actually
decreases and it turns out it has to be
like really [ __ ] acidic like more
acidic than your muscles would achieve
during exercise um
and so like i said there's a difference
between acidosis per se and acidosis as
a result of exercise and so basically
like the the way you would reach a point
of intense local acidosis in the context
of exercise is you're just doing a fair
bit of very high intensity exercise and
so you see muscular performance drop off
you see ph drop off those two things are
tightly associated and so it's it's
logical to assume that the ph is the
actual causative factor there but it
seems like it's not so one of the other
things that happens when you're doing
that really intense exercise
is you know you're you're splitting atp
into adp
in in a inorganic phosphate that kind of
drifts off uh and hopefully you know
your you're
burning energy fast enough that you can
resynthesize atp but when exercise is
intense enough that doesn't fully keep
up and so you get an accumulation of
inorganic phosphate within the muscle
which is also happening you know on the
same time course that ph is dropping
and the mechanistic research i've seen
suggests that the accumulation of
inorganic phosphate is actually more of
the causal factor that is reducing
muscular performance
suggesting that
you know if you
if you're taking a buffering supplement
to make sure your ph doesn't drop as far
you know that that reduction in acidosis
probably isn't actually going to affect
muscular performance all that much
because ultimately that's not doing
anything for inorganic phosphate
accumulation so you're you're
essentially trying to
fix a problem that may not
actually be as much of a problem as we
previously assumed it was um
now when when ph drops it so like
getting to your point of uh of beta
alanine doing a pretty good job for
improving performance for things lasting
like 90 seconds to maybe up to five
minutes or so uh so
one thing acidosis does do is it affects
uh energy metabolism basically so
when ph drops uh it kind of shifts
it shifts you away from like anaerobic
glycolytic metabolism like your your
muscles basically say like oh [ __ ] like
things are getting acidic let's stop
getting as acidic like let's do less
anaerobic glycolysis kind of slow things
down so we were mostly using more
aerobic metabolism and so it it kind of
makes sense that if you have that
kicking in really early and say like a
two-minute all-out sprint
that you
it's basically keeping you from tapping
quite as far into your anaerobic reserve
so it makes sense that a buffering
supplement would improve performance in
that regard but if you're talking about
you know even even like a high rep set
of 20 or something like that's not going
i i shouldn't state that too confidently
that's probably not primarily going to
be limited
by
glycolytic versus oxidative metabolism
that's probably going to be limited by
you know unrep 19 can you just produce
enough contractile force still and so
for for something like that that's going
to be limited far more by phosphate than
than acidosis per se so i think that
that could also partially explain why
like beta alanine does seem like it's
panning out pretty well for
uh like like anaerobic but like
endurancy type stuff uh but not quite as
much for lifting
yeah so i was aware that that research
was starting to
get some momentum which is why
i forget exactly how i phrased it but i
mentioned that uh you know drops in ph
have been associated with you know the
acceleration of fatigue
um but that does bring up a question so
like i remember back in the day
you had reviewed a
uh a mass
in mass you reviewed an article about
hyperventilation
and hyperventilation in that paper
seemed to be effective for prolonging
or delaying fatigue and increasing reps
to failure
was there an alternate mechanism that
they put forward there outside of
acid-base balance
i got to be honest with you i i don't
remember yeah because because i you know
i i definitely
i definitely do not subscribe to the
idea
that
ph uh
independently is is really driving
muscular fatigue in the typical lifting
scenario
um but but there are some of those
findings out there where you know you
you can find these instances of things
that uh you know in theory favorably
alter acid-base balance and and they do
seem in some circumstances to
enable more repetitions completed so
like uh there's the hyperventilation
study i'll link it in the show notes i
forget the the i was uh sakamoto and
colleagues
um you know but but they had basically
they had individuals hyperventilating
before sets um and they did i think six
sets to failure with bench press and leg
press uh and you know they're reaching
failure in the ballpark you know the
first set uh you know they were hitting
failure at like
uh
nine to 13 reps um and you know and then
of course it dropped from set to set um
but it was able to generally afford them
an extra couple reps per set
so i i don't know if i'm
ready to so
yeah
go go ahead i was just gonna say i'm not
sure if i'm ready to fully
uh bail on the entire concept of ph
being i i'm not ready to i haven't seen
enough yet to to say like oh this is
fully irrelevant um you know because
there are some of these findings you
know perhaps we don't understand that
the mechanism of these uh particular
uh interventions well enough you know
when it comes to things like beta
alanine and sodium bicarbonate and
hyperventilation even um but yeah yeah
it's definitely an area worth
exploring in greater detail for sure so
i i wonder
i wonder if if hyperventilation is maybe
less related to ph and more just related
to oxygen saturation where
um
so there
there was a paper on
repeated uh like cycle sprint intervals
from for maybe like 2013 2014 something
like that that was looking at not just
power output but also
uh the energy systems that that the
subjects were using across those those
uh
i think it was three
uh three bouts of of uh high intensity
cycling that that was either 15
either 15 or 30 seconds of pop
uh but what they found is that even
though
that at least like theoretically should
be a very anaerobic thing
what they found is that especially by
the third sprint uh they're it seemed
like their anaerobic energy systems like
basically weren't doing anything like uh
they were just so tapped out that they
were going as hard as they could but the
vast vast majority of the actual energy
was coming from aerobic metabolism
so it wouldn't surprise me if
maybe one of two things
were the case
uh so you know maybe just during the
first set or two you're kind of like
hyper saturating your blood and your
myoglobin with oxygen and so maybe
uh like in the first set or two you're
reaching failure just like purely due to
muscular fatigue but you haven't like
fully tapped out your anaerobic energy
systems and so they they still have a
little bit more juice to give on the
last few sets where maybe they wouldn't
have before
um
i said two things but no that's i'm
going to stick with one so that
i don't think that was offered by the
authors but that
is a other potential alternate
explanation and yeah like to be clear
i'm not um
i'm not ruling out
buffering supplements
do doing anything um
but
like basically what i'm trying to
at least hypothesize about is that they
seem to to have pretty reliable positive
effects for
you know things lasting to up to about
five minutes and more kind of like
endurancy type stuff like you know
sprinting 800 meters versus uh like
squatting a set of 15 or something like
that and one of those
uh
you know like both of them are going to
be impacted by metabolism and just can
you turn over atp fast enough
but the sprint
is is going to be
almost exclusively limited by that
whereas the resistance training
performance could be limited by that or
could just be limited by just sheer
ability to generate contractile force um
and so you know it could just be
something that varies individual to
individual like some people like you
know like the buffering might help
everyone when it comes to the 800 meter
sprint or but for resistance training it
could be that like some people are
failing the last rep vo1 mechanism where
buffering supplements would help some
people are failing the last rep via
another mechanism where buffering
supplements wouldn't help as much like
i i'm just saying that like in efforts
where just the sheer ability to generate
contractile force can be the limiter um
maybe you shouldn't expect buffering
supplements to
as reliably improve performance yeah and
that's definitely been reflected um
pretty much across the board with this
class of supplements you know
it's difficult to say oh you're never
gonna find a positive finding but there
is a lot more
variability from study to study where uh
you know you see some findings that look
promising and then you see some findings
that just make it seem like there's
really not much happening there you know
so uh i i think this conversation really
highlights the the general state of
uncertainty when it comes to
uh different buffering
techniques i guess because you know you
could lump in
uh sodium bicarbonate you could lump in
beta alanine but you could also lump in
targeted hyperventilation as a
non-supplement technique um but yeah
there's um despite the
high level of public interest in terms
of the supplement consumer
there's not a a lot of consistency in
the evidence and i think there are some
mechanistic details that really warrant
some further exploration so hopefully
people will uh will kind of
i'm sure that 80 90 of exercise
scientists do listen to this podcast so
hopefully you know we're going to see a
lot of masters and and phd thesis
projects coming up on these topics
uh one thing i did want to mention
briefly is um
there was a new paper on the combination
of anserine and carnosine i'm going to
be really brief with this because i
don't think there's a lot of practical
application yet um i did a quick search
and i don't think it's easy to find
anserine as a
human grade uh
supplement or food product i think it's
kind of difficult to find uh based on a
quick search
so um you know it's not like you're
gonna walk into vitamin shop or gnc and
say hey can you lead me to the anserine
it's it's not going to be there
but you might be able to find it
potentially on the internet i'm not
really sure but um anyway there's a new
paper from the same group that's really
been kind of
establishing the foundation of this
research looking at anserine and
carnosine and the
the concept here is you know beta
alanine like you said is is commonly
found in pre-workouts but there's really
not much of a reason to believe that
beta-alanine does much at all acutely
usually studies will say hey take this
for a month and we'll see if it did
anything or take it for two months maybe
so
the idea is that beta alanine slowly
over time is going to increase carnosine
content of your muscle
and then your muscle can actually use
the carnosine not the beta alanine to
actually do stuff that should help
that's kind of the theoretical
foundation there so you take
beta-alanine to increase carnosine over
time and intuitively people might wonder
why not just take carnosine seems
straightforward
the bioavailability is terrible
we have an enzyme in our blood called
carnosinase
and basically it breaks down the
carnosine into its constituent parts and
at that point you might as well have
just taken beta alanine it basically
splits the carnosine into beta alanine
and histidine and you already have more
than enough histidine uh so again it's
you might as well be taking beta alanine
in that context but
these researchers in this research group
have come up with a concept where you
take carnosine so that you saturate that
enzyme the carnosinase enzyme and then
you take anserine in combination which
is structurally similar to carnosine has
some similar physiological effects
but because the carnosinase enzyme is
dealing with all that carnosine the
anserine comes by and says hey i'm going
to go and do what chronic beta alanine
supplementation intends to do basically
so that's the thought process and
they've done a couple very preliminary
studies here
and so far it looks promising you know
they've been they're still in that phase
of research where they are explicitly
using
exercise tests that are like if this
does anything at all we have perfectly
designed a test to demonstrate that you
know so you we're not yet in a spot
where we can look at these preliminary
findings and say oh that's definitely
going to help with a set of 12. we're
not at all there yet
but there are some little glimpses
within this literature at some ergogenic
effects and i'm going to be very
interested to see how this body of
research develops and the reason i'm
interested is
everyone's kind of already decided that
they like beta alanine in their
pre-workout but that's not really doing
anything in the hour after you consume
it you know if you take it every day for
two months maybe we maybe we're working
with something but again even that
situation you're taking really a third
or a half of the beta alanine dose that
you would want to be taking on a daily
basis no one's putting
6.4 grams of beta-alanine in a
pre-workout at least not that i've seen
and if they did that would be pretty
unpleasant yeah usually if you have more
than two grams in a serving two or
three-ish
it varies obviously but that's usually
where you start to get a very tingly
face which isn't fun yeah you're gonna
feel like ants are crawling all over
your entire body yeah i think i've told
this story on the podcast before but i
was in an undergrad um
lab class
and we were supposed to like run a
little study to learn how studies work
and things like that all these people
wanted to do these totally benign
things that we could do very feasibly
and i said no no no class let's do a
beta alanine little mini trial and uh
the the
the graduate assistant teaching the
course messed up the the dosing oh no
and everyone's face felt like it was
just you know on fire just totally
tingling and everyone was
not pleased because like no one else
wanted to do beta alley and i was like
if we don't do beta alanine for this
project i'm out of here i'm walking like
i was so adamant and i it yeah the
dosing got messed up everybody's fine
yeah but it was not a pleasant afternoon
for anybody um but anyway so this um
carnosine and serine combination does
not seem to induce paresthesia that
tingling uh
as of now it looks like 40 to 60
milligrams per kilogram is the right
dose it looks like an hour before
exercise is the right time but what
we're going to have to figure out is
does this actually matter for lifters
we're not certain yet and then
somebody's got to actually produce this
and get it in the hands of consumers
assuming that the research pans out
effectively
but for now
we're talking about this off air
it looks like chicken broth is actually
a really nice uh
source of both of these so chicken broth
tends to provide carnosine and anserine
in a ratio of approximately one to two
or one to three uh varies a little bit
and there's actually a paper that i'll
link in the show notes that basically
reads like a cookbook they talk about
how they went through and made their own
chicken broth for this study measured
the the content of carnosine and
anserine um and the dose that they gave
provided uh
is close to getting in that range that
you would want in that 40 to 60
milligram per kilogram range and they
ended up giving 607
milliliters of chicken broth it was kind
of the average dose they gave they
scaled it to body mass they went with
eight milliliters per kilogram of body
weight um and and when i say you know
when i give that dosing guideline of 40
to 60 uh milligrams per kilogram that's
of each so 40 to 60 milligrams of
carnosine and 40 to 60 milligrams of
anserine
so i probably don't need to belabor the
point here because this is so
preliminary that it's not highly
feasible to implement but
uh it is an area of the research that i
think is really fascinating and i'm
going to keep an eye on so
for now the question of who actually
benefits from buffering supplements is
still very much open you know uh you
know you can have some very interesting
debates and arguments about this um i i
do still think there's at least enough
optimism that if you are
doing exercise where you
frequently find yourself uh
with burny muscles and feeling maybe a
little bit nauseous and you know you're
doing some of these circuit type
exercises these medleys some of this
crossfit type work that we see
uh i think there's still enough uh
interest and optimism there to say you
know if it doesn't break the bank if
it's within you know what what you can
afford and it's not something that
you're making huge sacrifices to
implement
it might not be a terrible idea to add
it in the mix but yeah there's a lot of
a lot of stuff about buffering
supplements that at this point is simply
not yet answered so we'll have to wait
and see now eric i'm i'm disappointed in
you because
for this last segment on ansarine
supplementation
you shared a very interesting tidbit
about anserine with me all fair that you
didn't just discuss on the podcast
what's that
so
either you told me this or it was in
your mass article but you you said that
uh
i think like all other vertebrates have
carnosine plus
something else that that does
essentially what carnosine does and
serene being one example yeah and that
humans are like the only vertebrate that
only has carnosine and not something
else that is my understanding that's
wild yeah yeah so there's these
different they call them
histidine-containing dipeptides
um and yeah my understanding based on
the reading that i was doing is that uh
mo all vertebrates except for humans
have some combination of these different
uh histidine-containing dipeptides we
just have the carnosine but but if we do
consume anserine exogenously it would
appear that we can still put it to use
that's wild man yeah
yeah that's that's about it yeah it is
kind of fun every now and then when you
find something interesting about um
you know i think the official term is
comparative physiology when you start
looking at how animals deal with
physiology and how humans differ in
certain contexts um that's that's one of
my biggest regrets um i was in school
for way too long i was in college for
what like nine or ten years
every step of the way undergrad master's
phd i searched far and wide for a course
on comparative physiology and i never
found a good one that i could work into
my curriculum uh which is
really a shame but i'm i'm honestly i
haven't given up on that yet i i still
intend to take a course so here here's a
reading recommendation for for you and
also just uh uh listeners of the podcast
the journal of experimental biology jeb
uh
it's well it's exactly what it sounds
like but it's uh you know it's it's
um like actual like high quality
experimental evidence uh like i don't
know what you're implying like like
physiology research on just like
different animals yeah and uh you know a
lot of it is like really like
specialized and and
stuff that quite frankly i'm not that
interested in like you know like fish
are slimy how do they go about producing
that slime like
kind of cool but
i don't know i just don't care that much
but i i'd say they have like two or
three articles per issue
where it's you know something related to
metabolism or muscular work output
in just like some some random animal
and i'd say like half the time that
shit's like really interesting yeah you
know i i have a kind of a related um
very brief anecdote but i was at um
uh
roger harris
he was like
the dude who really kicked off uh
creatine performance supplementation in
the american scientific literature that
you know the kind of journals that we
that we typically see i mean there had
been people kind of writing about it
um or you know athletes using it about a
decade prior but the real big push for
creatine research in the academic
journals roger harris had a big a big
role in that
and he also had a huge role in the same
thing for beta alanine like most people
would uh without question consider him
like uh you know the godfather of beta
alanine and i saw one of his final
lectures when he basically was was
hanging up the the cleats and walking
away from it and he was
virtually uh pleading with the audience
does anyone have access to hummingbirds
because like he kind of came from that
world of like if you want to really get
at something and understand how it works
a
a very creative way to do that is to
utilize animal models with unique
physiological characteristics and he was
trying to understand the role of calcium
in
the mechanistic
effects of beta alanine and he was like
dude i need hummingbirds who has
hummingbirds uh so yeah it's it's really
interesting to see when people uh are
doing interesting animal model research
uh all right so
that segment went way longer than i
expected yeah that's fine um but you
have a bunch of cool stuff to talk about
uh
from our neck of the woods talking a
little bit about macro factor
yeah yeah so i've got two segments i
have an article discussion and
uh a tech support segment that's not
really a tech support segment but that's
that's where we uh
uh talk about macro factor stuff
so the article discussion uh is the
first article the first new article that
we're sharing on the new macro factor
website uh it's not specifically an
article about macro factor so don't uh
you know don't be worried to pull that
up it's not like it's just like a long
form sales pitch it's a
um you know a unique informative article
i would say
but it's an article on
the
the drawbacks of various approaches to
dietary and weight management that
involve calorie counting
and
this was actually a very opportune time
for it to come out because
the maintenance phase podcast just had
just recently had
an episode about calorie counting and uh
it got shared in the stronger by science
facebook group
turns out uh it seems that the that
their audience and ours has has a pretty
fair bit of overlap um
and this is not a promise but they're so
they they said that their episode on
calories is going to be a two-parter and
only the first part is out
i
i may do a
uh
i don't know if i should call it a
review or a rebuttal or what just you
know a segment and a hit piece no
definitely not a hit piece a total
job but i would say a segment in
conversation with their episodes uh when
they when they when the second one comes
out i'm not guaranteeing i'll do that
but there's there's a decent chance that
i might um
but this this article uh you know i
didn't plan it i didn't know what they
were gonna put out but it's actually an
opportune time for it to be published
because i think it it does
relate pretty strongly to some of the
things they brought up in their first
episode about calories um
and so yeah like it's
it's an interesting question so uh the
the basic science of
calories is very straightforward you
know if you're
consistently eating fewer calories than
you expend you should lose weight if
you're consistently eating more than you
expend you should gain weight
and you know that that seems very simple
it seems like you have a model with two
variables calories in calories out not
too much to worry about and so
it seems like calorie counting should be
an almost foolproof method to
gain or lose weight when you want to and
at approximately the rate that you want
but you know
a lot of approaches to calorie counting
have been around for a long time and
they've been successful for a lot of
people but they also haven't been
particularly successful for a much
larger number of people
and so you know basically what i wanted
to
kind of investigate and explore in this
article is
why is that
so what i did
is is first just basically look around
and say like well okay
what
if people are going to be counting
calories what
general approaches do they use
to that end like how are they
determining their calorie targets that
are
hopefully going to get them where they
want to go
and there seem to be three broad
approaches people take so the first one
is
uh you know they
they just read somewhere that like hey
you know you should be aiming for this
number of calories and that is the right
number and and kind of the
uh
i think most iconic version of
this sort of recommendation is just the
recommendation given to a lot of female
dieters that like 1200 is the number aim
for 1200 if you hit 1200 cool you'll
lose weight good things will happen um
but you know i've seen some other
numbers proposed so a similar number
i've seen thrown out for men is like
1500 calories um
and you know th this sort of logic is
implicit on u.s nutrition labels like
they
they give you
percentages for calories macronutrients
saturated fat etc
like as a percentage of a 2000 calorie
diet like they they just kind of like
presuppose that's what people are aiming
for um and you know it says explicitly
on the label like you know this not
everyone needs to be aiming for 2000
calories like this is just an example
but i i think that um a lot of people do
just like implicitly interpret that as
kind of a one-size-fits-all calorie
target
uh and so
you know that's that's one method people
use another popular method that people
use uh more and more within the last
five to ten years
is using a wearable device that
estimates your energy expenditure so you
know like a like a fitbit uh like a
garmin watch apple watch something like
that um and you know those those devices
will
uh
i mean it's a it's a very rough estimate
of your energy expenditure but i think
people
assume that that it's like really
meticulously calculating your energy
expenditure so that's that's another uh
method people use to generate calorie
targets and then there's a third
approach which is
you know i think this is the go-to
approach uh certainly for people from
like the bodybuilding world also like
kind of the evidence-based fitness world
where you start with a calculator of
some sort a total daily energy
expenditure calculator or tdee
calculator um
where you know you might tell it your
age sex weight uh maybe body fat
percentage uh your activity levels and
it will estimate your total daily energy
expenditure and then it's like well okay
like now i know this number so if i just
eat below that uh you know i can lose
weight if i eat above that i can gain
weight at approximately the rate that i
want
uh so this article just basically goes
through and talks about
where those three approaches can break
down that may not be entirely obvious to
people who
you know maybe just don't coach people
or don't spend quite as much time in the
literature and so starting with the one
size fits all calorie targets uh this is
one that i feel like
most people in our audience will
agree maybe isn't the best way to
approach this um but it is i think the
most popular approach just in
kind of the the general diet culture um
and so the the most obvious downside of
this approach
is just that uh especially if you're
going with that 1200 number that's not
many calories and
you know there there are drawbacks to
having too low of a calorie target and
losing weight too fast so i don't want
to fear monger like
a decent number of people
can lose weight very quickly and
everything goes pretty smoothly for them
but a lot of people also will run into
problems so you know acutely
you know low energy fatigue
constant hunger cravings and chronically
if your calorie targets are too low
especially if you don't have a
sufficient resistance training stimulus
you might lose a lot of muscle and then
there's research suggesting that if you
lose a lot of muscle
or just a lot of lean mass when you're
dieting that is associated with
pretty pretty notable elevations in
appetite as your body is attempting to
regain that muscle that you lost which
not all the time but oftentimes just
leads to weight overshooting and
finding yourself in in the world of
yo-yo dieting which
is not a good place to be
but then the other
the other less common drawback to this
approach and i might catch some flack
for saying this but it's true so if
you're upset uh
i'm sorry i guess uh is that even those
low calorie targets for some people
might be a little bit too high so some
people find that you know i i'm eating
12 1300 calories per day i'm not losing
weight
you know
am i making mistakes like am i eating
way more than i think i am
and
most of the time you probably are but uh
there's
um so there was a 2021 study by ponzer
and colleagues that used uh doubly
labeled water data
with like 6 400 individuals from around
the globe to get a pretty good idea of
what
people's total daily energy expenditures
were
at different body weights and across the
life span
and what you see looking at their data
is that
the vast majority of adults do
expend
let's say like 1500 calories per day
plus
but
uh a minority of people are
uh like legitimately expending somewhere
in the 1000 to 1200 calories per day
range or not much over that so you know
if you're expending 1350 calories per
day if you're eating 1200 calories per
day uh
it's still not much but you also are
going to be losing weight very very
slowly so
uh you know the the problem to the to
the naked eye might look like no weight
loss at all correct you know over a
short time frame yeah and so the basic
problem with one size fits all targets
is that
one size does not fit all uh so what
whatever number someone throws out there
it will be a very appropriate calorie
target for
a minority of people and it will be way
too low for a pretty good chunk of
people and it might actually be too high
for a very small number of people so
that's
that's the the basic problem they're a
very popular approach to calorie
counting for the purpose of managing
nutrition losing weight uh
not quite as popular for gaining weight
i don't see people being like oh yeah
you want to gain weight just everyone
aimed for 5 000 calories um
but you know this is a very popular
approach people take and it has some
pretty clear downsides
uh the second popular approach that i
mentioned was using wearable devices to
estimate your energy expenditure
and you know then
essentially like if your if your
wearable device says oh you're burning
2500 calories per day you take that
pretty literally and say like okay well
if i'm down around uh 1800 to 2200 i
should be losing weight at a pretty
decent clip so cool like i can take that
to the bank use that to generate calorie
targets and be good to go
the problem is that wearable devices do
uh like a famously bad job of estimating
energy expenditure
and this is something that
i think like every researcher in the
area is very aware of
and maybe 10 percent of consumers are
aware of
um
so like there was a 2020 systematic
review that just plots
uh for for all of the studies that have
used wearable devices to estimate energy
expenditure at rest during different
exercises
etc it just plots them all on a single
graph so you can see what the mean
percentage error is for each device in
each study to just kind of get a broad
overview of how good of a job these
devices do again not not for individuals
like the the total range of individual
errors
will be larger than the total range of
average errors within the studies
conducted but so this
this figure shows you the
the range of errors for average uh
percentage estimates estimation errors
and so what you can see is that
you know they they kind of cluster
around zero uh which you know
you would hope that they would like if
if they did just like consistently
overestimate energy expenditure by 40
percent they'd be horrifically bad uh
but you know it does kind of cluster
around zero
but you see a lot of errors
that are like in the 50
plus or minus range so like if a
wearable device is saying oh yeah you're
burning
2 000 calories per day
it's possible that it's a thousand it's
possible that it's 3 000. um
and and kind of my
my point of saying like okay like this
is working well enough is basically like
is this producing errors that are
smaller than about ten percent like you
know i think that that's a fair amount
of error uh to allow for and also like
it's it's a practically useful amount of
error so if you're
say trying to be in a 500 calorie
deficit to lose about a pound per week
and you're burning 2500 calories per day
a 10 error would would mean essentially
that you know if you think you're in a
500 calorie deficit you might actually
be in a 250 calorie deficit you might be
in a 750 calorie deficit but you'll be
losing weight at around half a pound to
a pound and a half per week like you're
you're in the right general ballpark for
what you're aiming for
uh and
the the evidence like
very conclusively shows that errors that
are smaller than 10 in magnitude are far
less common than errors that are
considerably larger than 10 in magnitude
so uh yeah using a wearable device to
generate calorie targets for the purpose
of calorie counting to gain lose
maintain weight um you know for for a
minority of people they work really well
for the majority of people uh we we
pretty conclusively know that they don't
work well for that purpose
yeah that gets at a common thing that
you see which is like so if you've got
uh if you have
uh
you know run studies before
then you know one of the first things
you think about with any instrument is
what does it measure and
you know
you don't think what does the output say
you say no what does it measure right
right and i think a lot of the direct to
consumer type products
um there's just not enough emphasis on
that you know like
you'll you'll see um
instances where someone said like yeah i
got my metabolic rate measured and
you'll say oh how did you get it
measured and it'll be like in a bod pod
or like using a bis device or a bia
device and so like
a lot of these uh technologies that are
getting used a lot in commercial gym
settings and and direct-to-consumer
devices there's not enough emphasis in
my opinion on
what is being directly measured and from
that what is being estimated and i think
the more you dig into that you say like
oh this thing that's measuring your
energy expenditure
certainly is not measuring your energy
expenditure which is a really
a really uh
challenging thing to convey to people
like people don't enjoy hearing that
because they're like well then what did
i just buy you know but but it's an
important clarification yeah yeah so so
ultimately what wearable devices are
measuring
is they're measuring heart rate um
they're measuring
they're measuring movement
one of two or sometimes both ways uh
either via gps or via accelerometry uh
and some of them are also measuring body
temperature like a rough estimate of
body temperature like they're measuring
wrist temperature basically uh and
all three of those things are associated
with energy expenditure but it's it's
far from a one-to-one association
and
what we do know is the more of that data
that they consider so like a
something that measures all three so you
know let's say it's doing accelerometry
it's measuring heart rate and it's
measuring skin temperature
that will generate a better estimate
than something that is just accounting
for one of those like the the earliest
wearable devices
i think it was basically just heart rate
uh and
you generate really really just
piss-poor estimates of energy
expenditure if all you have to go off of
is heart rate you can generate a little
bit better estimates if you have both
heart rate and accelerometry or gps data
and you can generate a little better
estimate if you add skin temperature
into the mix
but all of those variables have
far from like a one-to-one relationship
like a an r equals one correlation with
energy expenditure
and so they they are it seems getting a
little bit better over time at
generating slightly more precise
estimates but i i mean we're still
we're still a long way away from those
being
very highly precise estimates yeah okay
and then the the third approach that
people commonly take
um
to
generating calorie targets to gain or
lose weight at a desired rate uh
is they basically use the formula
approach and maybe they do this by hand
or maybe they go to a website that has
one of these calculators built in
and
essentially what it does is
i mean much like i just described with
with wearable devices it will use
uh information about you that correlates
with energy expenditure to estimate your
basal metabolic rate so
uh depending on the equation being used
age sex weight body fat percentage
and body fat percentage would be to
estimate the total amount of lean mass
you have
all of those things are going to be
associated with basal metabolic rate you
plug all of that or some of those things
into a calculator and it will uh
generate an estimate of your basal
metabolic rate and then from there you
know you're you're doing more than
merely surviving like you're you're
doing some movement so then you multiply
that figure by
uh
by an energy multiplier or an activity
correction factor to then estimate your
total daily energy expenditure and then
you have that number
and you know you can use it to generate
calorie targets for the purpose of
gaining or losing weight but you know
that that begs the question much like
we've been talking about this whole time
uh what
what sort of error is associated with
that approach so you know
ideally you want to be able to pretty
reliably generate estimates of total
daily energy expenditure that are pretty
close to people's actual total daily
energy expenditure
and the interesting thing that i found
when i looked into this like you know
basically how how precise is that
estimate
what what i found and
it's possible i missed something but i
looked pretty hard um
so what i found is there's
an enormous amount of research uh
looking at how accurate and precise
uh bmr estimates are but i could not
find any research um uh validating or
looking at the relative accuracy and
precision of tdee estimates using
formulas like this um
so you know essentially so we know that
the bmr formulas are
i would say good but not great they they
do as good of a job as i think you could
reasonably expect them to do so
depending on the formula in question and
the population being studied the typical
error of these formulas is anywhere
between like maybe 150 calories and like
400 calories but you know mostly in like
the 200 calorie per day range so
if
if something tells you that your bmr is
1600 calories per day you can kind of
tack like a 200 plus or minus error
range on that and you know it it's
probably what did i say 1800 1600 i
think i said 16. so whatever so if it
says 1600
your bmr is probably
somewhere between 1400 and 1800
individual errors can certainly be
larger than that but in in all
probability it's within that 400 calorie
range 200 plus or minus uh which you
know could be more precise but given the
estim the the information being plugged
into that calculator um you know that's
i i feel like that's about as good as
you could reasonably hope for it to do
but then
the the next step of that process
going from a bmr estimate to a tdee
estimate is uh
that's more of a crap shoot so basically
there there are uh various sets of
activity multipliers that you can use
but by far the most common one i see
is 1.2 if you're sedentary 1.375 if
you're lightly active
1.55 if you're moderately active
1.725 if you're very active and 1.9 if
you are extremely active like those are
the the qualitative categories sedentary
through extremely active
and those those numbers i gave is what
you would multiply your bmr by to
estimate your total daily energy
expenditure
and so
you
immediately run into one problem which
is just how do you classify yourself uh
and so the the descriptions for these
aren't very helpful like they tend to
not disambiguate
lifestyle versus like dedicated exercise
so
for example the description for
sedentary is inactive job and very rare
or minimal exercise and so you know what
if you have an inactive job but you
exercise five days a week um you know it
it's it's hard to say or extremely
active uh hard daily exercise and other
regular physically demanding tasks so
what if you do hard daily exercise but
have a sedentary job you know so it's
it's hard to know which of these
categories you're supposed to fall in
and even beyond that uh this is this is
i think more subtle but even if everyone
did perfectly know
which one of those categories they fell
into
simply by by multiplying by kind of
bucketed activity factors you still
increase the estimation error for total
daily energy expenditure calculations so
you know let's say that you
um
you know let's say your total daily
energy expenditure is 1.45
times your basal metabolic rate so you
would fall in between lightly active and
moderately active and if you choose
either of those two multipliers that's
going to generate
somewhere around five percent additional
error just because those activity
factors are bucketed
and so with all of that information um
i was very curious like what
the relative accuracy of these tde
calculators actually were and like i
said i couldn't find any research on
that but
we we know enough that we can we can
model it uh pretty well so that's what i
did in this article and that at least
for me personally was the part that i
found most interesting and the part that
i liked writing about the most um so you
can you can check out the article to see
my methodology uh and also i i linked a
spreadsheet that you can use to tinker
with my assumptions if you want to
generate uh different estimates uh but i
i
you know tried to generate the most uh
the most justifiable set of assumptions
that i could uh in order to attempt to
quantitatively uh address this question
and uh so i was interested in
basically how often does this process
generate
a total daily energy expenditure
estimate that is close enough to your
actual total daily energy expenditure
that from the jump uh calorie targets
that you generate using this approach
will get you
pretty close to the desired rate of
weight gain or weight loss you want
and uh basically what i found is that it
works about half the time um
so for
about for a little less than 50 of
people the total error generated by this
approach
is less than 250 calories per day so you
know if you're
actually burning 3000 calories per day
uh you know maybe a calculator will say
32.50 maybe it'll say 27.50 but that's
in the right general ballpark if you're
trying to lose a pound a week you'll end
up losing half a pound to a pound and a
half per week like doing a pretty good
job
but for
the other approximately half of people
it's it's generating relatively
inappropriate calorie targets uh
which can for a very small minority of
people being be in excess of a thousand
calories per day which could mean if
you're trying to lose a pound per week
you're actually gaining a pound per week
which or losing three pounds per week
and in a huge deficit um
the the most
common kind of category of error was
between 250 and 500 calories per day uh
which would essentially mean that
if you were trying to lose a pound a
week you would be losing close to two
pounds per week or losing weight at a
essentially glacial pace like that that
was
about a third of people have errors on
that magnitude so essentially this
process is
it does a decent job of getting you in
the right general ballpark to start with
um
but you'll you'll definitely need to
uh make adjustments probably from the
jump for most people and certainly over
time as metabolic adaptation kicks in
um
and so then at the end full disclosure
there is a little macro factor pitch uh
you know essentially
once you have all of that information
you can make adjustments yourself you
know based on
your your rate of progress whether or
not you're plateauing or you can use a
software that that will do all of that
for you um
but yeah the the
90 of the article fully informative
little pitch there at the end if you're
mad about it uh that's okay
yeah just email greg if you're mad about
it email eric because he's the host of
the podcast so he let this segment
happen
i did i let it happen too long as well
we're way over time that's okay um
so uh i thought you did a great job with
this article and just to highlight what
you said um i think this article
is like
solid content for people who field
questions about or who have questions
about
hey um
why does there seem to be
why do so many people seem to struggle
with these standard approaches to
calorie-based interventions you know
it's so common that you hear people say
yeah calorie counting it doesn't really
work
and there is some truth to that you know
i mean the the physics you know works
but in terms of
just the the straightforward
intervention of calorie counting using
some of these strategies you can find
certainly instances where people have
done their very best to apply these
techniques and are not achieving the
type of results that they're looking for
and in some cases not even close so of
course you know energy balance exists
and works but you know this article goes
into some of the details of
really common errors that find their way
into a lot of real world approaches to
calorie counting and like you said
there's uh you know there's stuff in
here about
uh error from common equations error
from wearable technology so there's a
lot of good stuff in here that isn't
just a sales pitch i mean ultimately
what it comes down to is
there are two factors so if if an
approach to calorie counting is going to
work
you need to be able to
generate appropriate uh
calorie recommendations
and you need to be able to execute on
those recommendations and i think that
i think that one problem people run into
is what whatever approach they're using
to generate calorie recommendations like
of these three popular approaches
they
very understandably assume
that the
estimate that they're generating is a
highly accurate and precise estimate
when it isn't uh and i think that that a
lot of that falls on people who are who
are promoting this stuff because
you know ultimately with anything
there's there's some amount of error and
uh people rarely talk about that uh and
when they do
they they probably don't quantify just
how large those errors can be which can
make the dieter feel like like they've
failed when really they just weren't
aiming for the right numbers to begin
with um
and i think also like in a community
setting
that can get kind of toxic because if
you if you have a community where
you know
you go through a process you get a
calorie target
you as the dieter are doing a great job
of hitting that every day and you're not
seeing the results you want uh very
commonly i see people post about that
online like hey i use this calculator i
got these numbers like i'm trying to
lose weight i'm not losing weight and
then they just get a wall of responses
that's just like well you're [ __ ] up
like you're clearly eating way more than
you're tracking or like you're doing a
bad job somewhere like like this is on
you
when like you know sometimes it is but
uh i think more often than people
realize it's because they they just
weren't shooting for the right numbers
and i think that this also relates to
what is now
becoming a more popular refrain of of
you know people saying like oh like
calorie counting doesn't work like it
can't work like uh like it's it's so
complicated blah blah blah and like i
mean ultimately what i what i think it
comes down to is
a lot of people did try some of these
approaches and they had a really bad
experience
and what actually happened is they they
were just never shooting for the right
targets in the first place through to be
clear absolutely no fault of their own
and then when it didn't work out uh
the way that they
internalize that is oh well like
something must have happened with with
my hormones or like maybe there's
something
going on here that just calories and
calories out doesn't account for when
you know really it was just that they
they weren't shooting for the right
numbers um
and so yeah like i think that this is
is valuable information for people to
have because i i think
or at least i hope
it should clear up a lot of confusion
and and maybe even like ameliorate some
amount of guilt for people who have
tried some of these approaches before it
didn't work out for them and they didn't
know why um you know there's there's a
pretty good chance that
you did everything right and uh yeah you
just used an approach that didn't give
you an appropriate calorie target to
begin with yeah yeah i mean you know at
its core calorie counting does work um
but like you said you have to be
shooting for the right target and you
have to be uh you know in a position
where you're able to
sustainably and repeatedly hit that
target on a regular basis so if those
two factors come together you're in
great shape but you know there is a lot
of uh challenge associated with trying
to identify where that target should be
and as you alluded to adjusting that
target over time because it is not going
to be in the same place throughout the
entire course of a diet in most cases
um all right so we're we're like an hour
15 in
what do you want to do here
let's uh let's save tech support for
next time and uh okay play us out yeah
i'll i'll hit the people with a little
cliffhanger here every time i do that
people hate it but uh we basically uh
all of our segments today have taken
longer than than i thought they would
that's okay um so
here's what's gonna here's what's on the
menu the forecast for the future uh
i'm gonna circle back and talk about
practical
recommendations for implementing high
intensity interval training i teased
that last episode and failed to get to
it but that's okay
i'm gonna dig into some of this some of
the stuff we alluded to about the
mechanisms of buffering supplements
specifically for the contractile
properties of muscle you know to figure
out
what are the totality like what what
what are all the contributing
contributing mechanisms that might be
uh
you know
yielding effects for things like beta
alanine and
sodium bicarbonate and even
hyperventilation i'm going to try to
circle back to that even briefly to see
if i can dig up some clarity about
what some of these buffering supplements
might be doing if they're impacting uh
you know some of these um force related
outcomes without you know necessarily
maybe
low uh you know ph buffering is not
technically the thing that is driving
that effect i'm gonna dig into that a
little more see if i can provide the
people with a little more clarity
and then we're also going to have a tech
support segment that is going to talk
about some really really really big
changes to the food logger within macro
factor a huge huge huge
overhaul of the food locker the food
logger that has made it remarkably
efficient and fast so we're going to
talk a little bit about what went into
that overhaul and that kind of a
reimagination of the logging process
and we even have some
quantifiable data to support uh you know
some of that excitement about speed and
efficiency so we're going to get to all
that stuff later
but this is about all the time we have
for today's episode so to play us out um
i'm gonna start off with uh oh did you
remove your yogurt yeah i did the the
thing i have is
very cool but not yogurt related okay oh
but you do have something yes okay cool
so i'll go briefly here um i mentioned
that i'm gonna start giving some
not television and movie media
recommendations mostly gonna be music
and podcasts i talked about radiohead
last episode
i've got another band recommendation um
and one of the bands i really love one
of my favorites is wilco
and they're a really interesting band
they are not i don't think they're as
widely known as radiohead
but wilco is a really fascinating band
they've been putting out studio albums
consistently since like
1995 and they actually just released one
three days ago
and it's not like one of those things
we're like hey let's get back together
for one more they've been trickling out
albums for you know decades now
and if you want to know what genre they
are i don't really know where to begin
um they will generally generally be
categorized as
alternative country
but i don't think that does a good job
of really describing what they are
there's
there's a little bit of folk influence a
little bit of bluegrass
a little bit of indie rock there are
guitarists since 2004
really is mostly a jazz guitarist um so
it's just a and there's there's a lot of
experimental elements mixed in when it
comes to instrumentation and song
structure um so yeah it's a little bit
of everything that kind of comes
together and uh i really like music that
is very
complex and textured you know like i i
like bands that use a lot of different
time signatures and different
instrumentation and one of the things
wilco does from time to time is during a
song they'll kind of reach a crescendo
that gets a bit chaotic it's a little
bit jazz like in that fashion and you
kind of start to feel like the band has
fully lost sync
but then they kind of fall back in and
you realize it was all under control all
along it's a very unique thing that they
do from time to time but um yeah really
really fascinating band and they have
kind of that radiohead thing going on
where
they span a few different genres to some
extent so depending on where you jump in
with an album you're not necessarily
certain uh exactly what you're going to
get so this is another band that if you
want to dive in you've got what about
25 30 years worth of music that you can
dive into so there's there's a lot to
get to uh i would recommend starting
with one of two albums i think summer
teeth is a great album and i really love
yankee hotel foxtrot
good deal so my my little to play us out
thing uh is about everyone's favorite
topic and that is likens um
so uh my my pocket recommendations like
when i when i open up a new tab on
firefox uh just recommended me this
article from the atlantic from 2016 by
ed yong
and uh i found it completely fascinating
so i grew up in the woods
um
and you know there were well in a house
in the woods
i i probably spent more time in the
woods than in the house okay um
but yeah so the the hou the house i grew
up in was in the in the middle of the
woods and so you know you're just
walking through the woods and there's
just lichens all over the rocks all over
the trees like it was a pretty
ubiquitous thing
and then when i got to either like
middle school or high school and learned
what lichens were
i found them very fascinating so they're
it's it's like a whole class of organism
that is not a single organism like it's
it's a symbiotic organism so uh lichens
are not just a thing uh every lichen you
see is and this is what we learned is is
the union between a fungus and in algia
uh i'm just gonna say algae because
that's the plural but i don't care you
do the the british pronunciation of
algae
i'm saying algae okay uh but yeah so
essentially the way lichens work is and
or what i learned is that the fungus
basically helps provide structure for
the compound organism
and you know can can also help with like
uh digesting
dead plant matter to get
a bunch of nutrients but then the algae
does photosynthesis to help you know
generate the actual glucose needed for
the combined organism so it's a
symbiotic relationship they both get
something out of it the algae gets
protection and nutrients and the the
fungus gets energy basically
um
and so i just thought that was so cool
and uh it turns out that that is not to
the whole story the whole story is even
cooler so
one of the problems that scientists were
having apparently is they couldn't get
lichens to grow in a lab and that is a
surprising thing because since lichens
aren't
a single organism they don't reproduce
the way a normal organism does like it
can't put out a like and spore or a
lichen seed or like an egg because it's
it's two things that both reproduce
different ways so it's thought that the
way that lichens come to be
is essentially you just kind of have
like a fungus and an algae in the same
place at the same time and they just
kind of like spontaneously organize
into this this compound organism um
and so in theory it seems like it should
be very easy to make that happen in the
lab like if if it's happening all the
time in nature we're just like these two
things are coming in contact and like
yeah it just works out you would think
you'd be able to figure out the
circumstances necessary to do that under
uh like in controlled conditions uh but
scientists couldn't like they just
couldn't get
lichens to grow in the lab in in a
predictable way
and um
turns out there was
at least in the context of algae science
a pretty recent discovery i think this
article says it was 2011 which is that
we were all wrong about lichens it's not
a fungus and an algae it's actually too
fun fungi in an algae and that's very
important um
because in it and it was very surprising
because essentially the second fungus
uh
looks the same as the first fungus under
the microscope and that's how like most
of this research was done via microscopy
and you know you're just looking at
slices of it and the two different fungi
look the same like there's no reason to
assume that it's two instead of just one
uh but um
eventually they they basically did some
genetic analysis of uh
of lichens and they found that there's
you know that basically like there were
a lot of genes being expressed that
weren't within like the main funguses
genome and weren't within the algae's
genome and they're like oh [ __ ] there's
another fungus here uh so it is actually
a compound organism with three different
things going on that still manages to
uh like spontaneously organize and grow
and
do so kind of all the time and kind of
everywhere
which is fascinating and i haven't
checked in on on lichen studies but uh
yeah this article is from 2016.
hopefully scientists are having a better
job growing lichens in the lab these
days um but i just found that very cool
that something
so basic that that was such a ubiquitous
part of my life um
like lichens were everywhere that
just like what they're made of uh wasn't
fully discovered and i mean i don't know
i i i might be
this might be scientific hubris maybe
there's even more going on but uh it at
least like a third fungus
who knows but yeah it's like an algae
like something that momentous that like
hey there's a whole there's another
thing here uh that that we just learned
about that as a species
10 years ago
after likens had been studied for
hundreds of years with lab equipment uh
so i found that a very very interesting
and that article will be linked in the
show notes man i didn't know that you
had such a strong connection to lichens
because i would have invited you over i
had a tree expert come by the other day
because i'm trying to
avoid having all my trees fall on my
home
and uh
he uh he pointed out some lichens that
i've got going on um of course not a
problem
but it was cool though uh
i am intrigued by
expertise in all forms like when
somebody really knows their [ __ ] and is
just doing their thing uh it always
impresses me no matter what they're
doing it was so cool like we were
walking around my yard he's looking at
the trees and you know he'll take out a
hammer and tap it and go
and i'm just like god what's going on in
his head uh in one case he he went up to
the the bark of the tree cupped his
hands and
took a big sniff and was like all right
not bad and i'm like dude what are you
thinking like what is happening in there
i was like just blown away by the
you know it's the type of thing that you
just have to feel it and you have to
have the the years of experience to
really know what you're doing but yeah
expertise in all forms will always get
me but if you want to come check out
some likens i can point them out for you
i would definitely not say i'm a like an
expert but i like them i think they're
cool uh and they're nice to look at yeah
all right um so that does it for this
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
as always thank you for joining us and
we will be back soon with another
episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you could sign up for the free
newsletter at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit
the links for both are provided in the
description of today's episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you